مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في مجزيلن قال رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اسرائيل تفاجئ ايران
دوما وسوف تفاجئ كل اعدائها حسب قوله وكان
رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي قال نيران
تقدمت في تخصيب اليورانيوم عاد نحو غير
مسبوق
من جهه قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي لسلاح
الجو نفذ عملياته خلال المواجهه الاخيره
في غزه بنجاح كبير ودعا السلاح الجو
للبقاء على اهبه الاستعداد في المقابل حذر
مسؤوله ايراني من ان استهداف منشات بلاده
النوويه يعني اشعال حرب واسعه تتحمل
اسرائيل مسؤوليتها وقال المسؤول الايراني
للجزيره ان كلام اسرائيل عن استعدادها
لضرب منشات ايران نوويه هو ارهاب رسمي
يقابل بصمت دولي
قالت المتحدثه بس بهيئه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه انه لا معنى لاي تهديدات تشمل
الصناعه النوويه الايرانيه واضاف ان هذه
الصناعه باتت محليه ومتجذره حسب تعبيره
واكد ان العدو يدرك انه لا يمكن ازاله
قدرات ايران نوويه حسب قوله
افاد حاكم ومقاطعه الروسيه بان طائره بدون
طيار القت عبوه متفجره على احد الطرق في
المقاطعه واشار الى عدم تسجيل اي اصابه
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت القضاء
على من تبقى ممن وصفتهم بمجموعات القوميين
الاوكرانيين الذين هاجموا مقاطعه واضافت
انه تم صدو المجموعات الاوكرانيه من خلال
الضربات الجويه ونيران المدفعيه
في المقابل لاكدت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ان بلادها لا تقوم باي عمليات
داخل الاراضي الروسيه وان من يقف وراء ذلك
مواطنون روس مستائون من نظام بوتين على حد
تعبيرها
اما منسق والاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي فقال ان واشنطن لا
تشجع ولا توفروا اي دعم من الهجوم على
الاراضي الروسيه وفق تعبيره
السودان تراجعت حده المعارك في اليوم
الاول من هدنه الايام السبعه وشهدت مناطق
ام درمان والابيض اطلاق نار متقطع بعد
ساعات من دخول الهدنه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه حيزه تنفيذ واكدت
وانشطه انها تناقش مع مجموعه مراقبه
الهدنه تقاريرا عن الانتهاكات وقالت الامم
المتحده انها تسعى الى توسيع عملياتها
الانسانيه وحذرت من التداعيات الاقليميه
للصراع
قالت الخارجيه السعوديه ان المملكه
والولايات المتحده
ابلغتا ترهي الصراع بوجود انتهاكات للهدنه
في الخرطومه الابيض وطالبتاه او طرفين
بالالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار المبرم بين
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع في جده يوم 20 من مايو
ختام هذا في امان الله
[موسيقى]